I removed the core combo for my bracket
four pirate deck along with some of the
supporting cards for it, replacing them
with some more generalist cards along
with a couple bizarre finishers. Well,
it wasn't exactly a replacement. The
original deck is still fully playable,
but I made a 10-card swap-out package
that could be implemented to move the
deck down from a cutthroat high-power
combo deck that usually wins on turn
five to a grandier pirate mid-range deck
that usually wins on more like turn
eight to 10. On the surface, that sounds
fine, great even. I have a deck whose
core I like and I get to split it into a
high-powered bracket four style version
and a more mid-powered three style
version. However, the resulting
theoretically mid-powered deck feels
very strange to play and I think it
points to some odd truths about what it
means for a deck to be a particular
power level. Something that might have
already caught your attention is that 10
card number. A firmly bracket four deck
is really just 10 cards from being a
totally fair bracket three deck? And
this wasn't swapping 10 good cards for
10 bad cards either. This was more like
swapping one insanely good card and nine
highly specific support cards for 10
generally decent cards. So, how does
that work? Well, to get into that, I
need to start by covering what the
original deck does. This deck was
intended to be the most powerful
possible pirate deck I could make on a
$100 budget and it does so by leveraging
its command zone extremely aggressively.
Princess is a two-mana flying pirate
that filters whenever one or more
pirates hit an opponent and Malcolm is a
three-mana flying pirate that makes a
treasure whenever one or more of my
pirates hit an opponent. So, the core of
this deck ended up being these two
paired with a one-mana pirate to get the
deck set up with a powerful early
engine. This engine builds into a combo
turn with Time Sieve, a two-mana
artifact that can sacrifice five
artifacts to grant an extra turn.
Malcolm creates three artifacts per turn
as long as I'm hitting three players, so
all this required to keep taking turns
with Time Sieve is a card like Academy
Manufacturer, Renegade File Duplication,
or Storm the Legion Negotiator that can
close that gap with some extra artifacts
per turn. Paired with a bunch of tutors
and draw engines to find the various
pieces and an eye-watering 13 counter
spells to keep my plans safe with spare
treasures, this deck can pretty reliably
yield well-protected combo wins on turn
five to six. So, this is a pretty strong
deck, but it's also not one I've ended
up playing with a whole lot. I love
playing a highly interactive deck with
lots of evasive creatures and coastal
piracy effects, but this deck was that
plus a fast combo win. So, it just
doesn't feel right in most games. And
fundamentally, this is why I was
interested in creating a pivot for this
deck to let my pirate guys see more
games. The budget of this deck also
might make it more clear why I thought
10 cards would be a fine number to swap
out. The card quality here just isn't
that high.
There are no game-changers in this
original deck and not a whole lot of
what you might consider staples. If we
look at the 13 counter spells in
particular, there are a lot of weird
ones you might not have heard of. Spell
snare, lookout's dispersal, memory
lapse. I also run every one-mana pirate
in the game, including the vanilla heavy
hitter grasping scoundrel and the Foglio
classic that is cloud pirates. So,
surely, I figured, this would be an easy
power down. My deck is full of dog
so I'll just cut the time sieve, some
tutors, and some of the hyper low-cost
interaction spells.
In their place will come in a few pieces
of creature removal, a few value
engines, another land, and a few much
goofier win cons. One of these win cons
is Vorpal Sword, an equipment that can
turn an evasive creature and 11 total
mana into a dead opponent in short
order. The other two are the commander
storm cards skull storm and echo storm,
which help mitigate the weakness of this
deck getting its commanders shut down a
lot. All three of these are pieces of
tech that I tried out in the higher
power version of the deck, but which
didn't really make sense in terms of
power level, and it's satisfying to be
able to still let them live in a version
of this deck. So, here was the deck, now
split into two. I double sleeved the
whole deck in Dragon Shield outer
sleeves and then color coded the two
10-card swap packages with ordinary
colored sleeves. If you want to attempt
something similar with these outer
sleeves, follow my affiliate link in the
description and use code Salubrious at
checkout. That aside, how did this new
version of the deck feel? Was it indeed
a mid-power deck?
Well, I can't say the answer to that is
no. It has won a pretty unremarkable
number of games, and it usually
threatens wins on a timeline that's
pretty normal for a bracket three deck,
usually around turn eight to nine. The
overall plan for the deck is evasive
creature beatdown with a lot of effects
that generate value when combat damage
is dealt. And the deck's more dedicated
win cons dovetail naturally from this
commander-centric light pirate beats
plan.
However, there is still a distinctly
weird character to this deck, and that
comes from how precision-built it is to
be strong early in the game, and how
much protection it has for its game
plan.
If it does indeed land turn one private,
turn two Francisco, turn three Malcolm,
or an equivalently strong roll out, it
starts building up resources really
fast. Three treasures a turn is pretty
standard, and with one of the seven
coastal piracy effects in this version
of the deck, it will also often be
drawing three cards a turn starting on
turn four, with that number often
scaling up quite a bit within a couple
turns.
The deck does exactly what you would
want a deck to do as it's gearing up for
a crushing turn five or six win, because
that's what the core of this deck was
designed to do. But in this version of
the deck, that crushing win never quite
materializes.
The deck just keeps drawing cards and
making treasures and playing pirates
until either it finds one of its
finishers, wins through critical mass,
or loses its footing and falls behind.
This effect is amplified by the deck's
interaction suite. The original deck had
13 counterspells and a pirate that can
be sacrificed to protect something, as
well as seven removal spells. This new
version effectively trades three
one-mana counterspells for a set of
creature removal tools that cost three,
four, and nine mana, respectively.
In terms of this deck's ability to slow
opponents, this feels pretty fine. 17 of
the next 20 interactive tools are
single-target in nature, and half of the
deck's counter spells can't even hit
creatures.
This deck can draw a lot of cards and
create a decent number of treasures, but
it's just not capable of keeping the
whole table suppressed for any
significant length of time.
However, I've had several games where
this deck did seem to give off
controlling pub stomper energy, and that
fact fundamentally comes down to the
protection suite here. This deck is
carefully engineered to be as good at
protecting its board as possible right
from the first Malcolm trigger on turn
three. In the original version, there
were 14 protective tools, mostly counter
spells, and here that number drops to
11, but in a deck with plentiful draw
and filtering, that still ends up
feeling plenty large. And this feature
intersects with the deck's early power
spike in some really interesting ways.
If on turn four I have three pirates and
creating three treasures per turn and
I'm drawing three or more cards per
turn, that generally makes me the early
big bad of a bracket of a
three-commander game. Then, when the
removal inevitably starts flying, I get
to effortlessly brush it aside with my
plentiful treasure mana, even if I
tapped out, and my draw engines will
typically draw me into more counter
spells and additional draw engines,
which will in turn draw me into even
more protection for my commanders. In
the most extreme games, I've thrown out
five or more counter spells to protect
my board in the first six turns of the
game, all while drawing piles upon piles
of cards through a wide board of pirates
and multiple coastal piracy effects. And
just think about how this looks for my
opponents. I'm the deck that's drawing
eight cards per turn with my board of
many permanents and countering removal
spell after removal spell, seemingly
executing an unstoppable game plan with
cold precision. Every attempt to slow me
down falls short, every point of
resistance anticipated. I'd call this
pub stomping, but it's more like pub
stomp simulator because I'm not actually
dealing a lot of damage or removing a
lot of opposing threats. I'm just doing
all of the other things that a pub
stomping player would do. This is made
all the worse because when this deck
does lose its foothold, it's not usually
because my opponent's got off a sick
Alpha Strike spell or landed a perfectly
timed board wipe. The first couple of
those got countered. Instead, the deck
falls behind with a whimper, taking
damage and losing permanence here or
there until it's forced to allow board
wipe to resolve, or alternatively forced
to offer up its board as blocks in the
face of an overwhelming attack. It does
succumb to pressure, but it feels more
like collapsing under its own weight
than getting put in its place by an
opponent. In a dedicated playgroup, I
think basically all of this deck's
weirdness would melt away after playing
against it a handful of times. If you
know the next formula, early power
spike, glut of single-target
interaction, Commander storm cards to
give a second wind after an eventual
falloff, in that case none of this feels
all that scary anymore. On the other
hand, the people at the LGS seeing this
for the first time, maybe even meeting
me for the first time, they're
interpreting opposing decks through the
lens of decks they've already played
against, and based on the idiocultures
of the Magic the Gathering spaces they
inhabit. And this feature can go the
opposite way as well. Just as me drawing
half a dozen cards per turn doesn't
necessarily signal being unstoppably far
ahead in an early game-centered deck
like this, seeing somebody doing
entirely mundane things in a late
game-centered deck could easily be
actually quite problematic. In my
Sharuum control deck, I've noticed that
if I'm not clearly behind on turn five,
I'm actually ahead. If my life total is
still in the 30s, my hand is decently
stocked, and my board isn't utterly
dwarfed by that of my opponents, I
probably have at least a 40% chance of
winning the game. And that just comes
down to the deck being engineered to
utterly dominate in the late game. I do
try to communicate this power profile
because I want a fair game. Hey folks,
this is my Sharuum control deck. I sure
hope I make it to the late game and get
to do awesome stuff with Astral Slide. I
likewise do a bit of that with the
bracket three version of my Pirates
deck, communicating that my two most
powerful win cons are Vorpal Sword and
Haunted One. But, with both of these
decks, communication can only go so far,
and that comes down to yet another
challenge of Commander with randos, the
complexity.
With a play group, you can get to know
all of your opponent's decks ins and
outs and have an intuitive feel for when
a deck is or isn't having a good game.
But, with fresh opponents and less
familiar decks, that can be a lot more
challenging. Even if somebody tells you
the rough profile of their deck, that's
something you need to remember alongside
all the other things happening, and
their account might omit details or
include built-in assumptions that you
don't necessarily share.
So, people go based on what they can
see, life total, cards in hand, and
especially what's on board. If I'm there
with a wide board of pirates resolving
12 combat damage triggers per turn, it's
easy for the person quietly ramping or
tutoring or setting up synergy pieces to
fall into the background. Likewise, that
background person is me when I'm playing
one of my greedier decks.
Fundamentally, the biggest thing this
comes down to is how telegraphed a deck
is in what it's doing. A deck that's
beating the I'm a problem drum starting
on turn four with a flurry of activity
on board is going to be much more
noticed and more easily kept under
control than a deck whose resources are
more subtle. A deck that wins highly
visibly on turn six could easily feel
much more fair to a table of strangers
than a deck who pulls a combo win out of
nowhere on turn seven, even if the turn
six deck is theoretically the stronger
one. This all could sound like a problem
of some sort, but to me it's ultimately
more of an interesting observation. Yes,
tables with less familiar players are
going to be different than tables within
a play group, and those distinctions are
interesting to dive into, but in neither
place is this pub stomping simulator
pirates deck truly a problem.
It feels like it swims against the
social forces of playing Commander with
strangers, but so does any deck that
dares stray from the most conventional
molds of Commander decks. And even if my
spidey senses feel like they're picking
up on some social friction when I'm
hitting my strongest turns with this
deck. Ultimately, I don't think most
people are walking away from playing
against this deck having their day made
worse for it. They're just playing
Commander just like anybody else.
Thanks for watching and thanks to
Architect for supporting the channel.
Architect's maybe board categories give
me an elegant way to do something weird
like this with the deck. And if you want
to take a look at this deck's list, you
can find that down in the description.
I'd also like to thank my supporters on
YouTube and Patreon, some of whom are on
screen now. If you want to support me in
making this sort of content, as well as
disappearing to Serbia occasionally, you
can join my Patreon or sign up for a
YouTube membership today.